Comunque assurdo il fatto che ti segui
al 2013
No ragazzi scherzavo Sofia che fa gli
effetti specialista qua che per terrazzo
via vieni
no È stato incredibile Perché
È lei che ha fatto gli effetti fa queste
cose qua Comunque siccome vogliamo
spiegarvi un attimo che cosa sta
succedendo
facciamo un po' una chiacchiera in
studio Un po' con lei vi spieghiamo un
po' la situazione
riesci a fare che compariamo in studio
tipo non so
Brava Grazie
funziona anche per viaggiare in Giappone
no Oggi faremo
un'intervista io non ho mai fatto
interviste non sono molto curioso Nel
senso che allora io Vabbè mi ricordo di
venire ai raduni eccetera quando facevo
mi interessano gli effetti speciali da
sempre questa situazione qua cade a
fagiuolo perché mi interessa parti
domande io qua questa cartelletta che è
pieno non è vero non serve a niente c'ho
il telefono faccio col telefono ogni
volta che durante questa intervista noi
diremo la parola effetti speciali o
anche solo effetti tu imposto dovrai
fare un effetto speciale sei pronta
paga Giampiero
ho iniziato a guardare i miei video Ai
tempi perché hai fatto questa cosa
perché ti vuoi male così tanto sperma
proprio fissata con i tuoi video ogni
giorno tornavo a casa la scuola facevo
le medie È una cosa che facevo mangiavo
guardavo il tuo video lo scaricavo e lo
Divo Sì tutto dittavi i miei video no
nel senso per la fanpage Ah ok ok
Aveva una fan page su di me Vedo che la
costanza alla fine Premia a quanto pare
non so chi sia sta Costanzo però dico
noi molto gentile ad avermi dato questa
possibilità di intrattenerti come tante
persone che mi hanno seguito Grazie
ragazzi Io ho fatto nel mio meglio
effettivamente qualcosa di buono ne è
uscito pure fuori eh si interrompo ma
ogni singola persona Però è una fan page
su di te Oggi ha una carriera in
comunicazione il management
organizzazione eventi grafica video
making non scherzo cioè
forgiate il mondo perché siamo forti
come su tutti gli haters
quando so come funzionano determinate
cose anche dietro le quinte non riesco
più a guardare dei film piuttosto che
cose simili senza avere l'occhio critico
E io lo so che tu lo so perfettamente
perché anche io questa roba quindi non
immagino te con gli effetti speciali io
non riesco più a godermi un lavoro
spensierato perché ogni volta devo avere
l'occhio critico di là questo l'hanno
fatto così questo l'hanno fatto cosa
ogni singola scena lì a vedere Oddio ma
questo come Oddio ma questo lo so fare
Oddio della Marvel stiamo parlando della
Marvel quindi non mica Happy Wheels Però
vabbè adesso Vorrei che mi dicessi un
attimo perché non li so bene tutti cioè
io ho visto la tua pagina di Instagram
Però sinceramente io non so bene perché
Cosa hai lavorato ho visto un po' di
cose qua e là e ho detto wow però non ho
approfondito Volevo che fossi tu a
dirmelo tu hai fatto dei video anche per
artisti importantissimi tipo di Brava
brava
Vegas
il video dei Mates ci sono anche io che
compaiono con un ologramma è stata lei
ecco quando lavori personaggi di spicco
A livello mondiale quindi email non ti
senti di avere una sorta di
responsabilità oltre i limiti cioè se
non stai facendo una roba neanche che si
rimane in Italia proprio nel mondo
quindi una cosa cioè non immagino tipo
l'effettista come si dice della Marvel
quando deve stare non dorme
probabilmente ce sta lì quindi non ti
senti di avere una responsabilità
incredibile Quando fai dei lavori di
questo calibro assolutamente io anche la
sindrome dell'impostore Quindi io sento
che conosci No probabilmente mettiamo un
gas ovvero quando fai un lavoro magari
enorme e speciale tu dici Ma io non
appartengo a questo io non sono
abbastanza bravo Non me lo meritavo Qual
è stata la prima volta che hai sentito
più o meno questa sindrome dell'imposto
i video lyrics di traves licence perché
è stato il primo lavoro
di drivers licence che quindi è quella
canzone più cioè tutto tutto sbagliato
cioè No in realtà tutto giusto a livello
di progetti hai una domanda abbastanza
scontata Però in realtà è una domanda
scontata che mi interessa a livello di
progetti futuri tu Allora io la riporta
anche un po' su me stesso non
pregocentesimo Ma perché ti spiego
facendo un lavoro creativo Almeno io la
vivo così io da creativo quando mi
chiedono progetti futuri rispondo sempre
Boh Perché non so bene dove vado a
finire Io mi vivo la creatività giorno
per giorno Domani potrò fare un film
Come potrò fare No l'ho trovato Come
potrò fare qualcosa di divertente che mi
piace ma non so bene definirti che cosa
Quindi tu hai un futuro già organizzato
più o meno sai dove vuoi arrivare o non
lo sai allora penso di avere dei
checkpoint ma in passato ero molto più
fissata con questi obiettivi di quanto
non sia adesso Ora sto cercando un po'
di godermi il momento di vedere come
vanno le cose dove mi porta la vita come
è tutta una carriera molto imprevedibile
perché sei per le tue non hai un datore
di lavoro quindi non lo so Non saprei
dirti penso mi piacerebbe andare in
America a vivere li danno molto più
valore al mio tipo di arte che qui Mi
verrebbe da dire che parlano anche di
più
abbiamo tutte le ragioni del mondo penso
Los Angeles sei mai stato sì per lavoro
però ora torno per tre mesi a gennaio Ah
ci vai per tre mesi a vivere cerco di
trovare un visto ma senza visto Certo ma
sempre per lavoro vai per tre mesi così
perché vuoi andare a Los Angeles
fighissimo perché voglio fare un
film Beh sicuramente non so se Hollywood
guarderà questo video però ti ringrazio
per la fiducia figli di produttori di
Hollywood
è la classica domanda che fanno i
provini del Grande Fratello questa Dillo
in inglese Va bene ma io ti auguro di
finire in tutti i film del Mondo di
realizzare tutti i film del mondo che io
li guardo e dico penso che non esiste
perché io ho fatto i video su Happy
Wheels Ragazzi grazie di aver
partecipato a questo video Sofia ma
grazie a te perché sennò a quest'ora i
miei video dovrebbero meno qualità
perché questo se c'è una qualità
incredibile tutti gli effetti che avete
visto li ha fatti Lei ha detto di nuovo
effetti Quindi c'è un altro effetto
basta smetto di dire questa parola ci
vediamo al prossimo video e
Ciao Come mai Come concludere i nuovi
video come si conclude questo video
secondo voi con un effetto speciale con
un effetto speciale Allora effetto
speciale